Next up we're talking about bind widget, bind widget animations and synchronize properties.
So these are all different functionalities that we can use to facilitate communicating from our blueprint down to our C++
and being able to do various things in C++ that we can kind of trust either ourselves at a later date
or some other member of our team possibly designers or more visually oriented people
can utilize functionality that we've done in C++ without having to worry too much exactly about
the way our implementation works. So first off bind widgets. Bind widgets is a Mesopets specifier that
you can put on widget pointers in our user widget classes and it allows the designer to populate
native C++ level members with a designer created widget. This kind of flies in the face of general
unreal development pipeline the blueprint layer sitting on top of a C++ one in this case we're
essentially leaving a gap in the C++ layer for the blueprint layer to fill in for us.
So let's talk through a practical example let's say that we've got a C++ base class off of a
user widget with a text block member and the text block container is exactly what you'd think
a widget capable of rendering text in UMG I've kind of already mentioned that a little bit earlier
in the in the session if we flag this up with the bind widget specifier we're saying that
to the compiler this particular widget is populated from the designer layer we kind of said
it will exist at some point but we don't actually need to initialize ourselves in code
we would like we would with something like an actor component or something like that
we're just going to say that we're going to work with this bit of information but it's
actually going to get created later down the inheritance hierarchy by someone on top in
the blueprint layer. This frees up any UI designers to implement the text box and change
its visuals its positions its parenting we're not baking in you know how this is childed
we're not baking anything by its hierarchy we're just simply saying there will be a text widget
with this name and we're going to do some things with it anything else that gets done with it
that's kind of up to whoever is putting that into place and as engineers we're now going
to free this we're kind of free to assume that this is now valid and we can carry on
developing as we would otherwise this is also kind of just as a flow optimization it just kind
of means that we can kind of offload some of that thinking about exactly how this stuff is going to
be laid out to kind of further down the road again whether that's us a later date or whether
that's someone else on the team it just means that we can kind of work with the bits that
really matter and not get really really hung up on you know what is the exact hierarchical
structure of all of these things. So one question you might have is that like if we're saying
you know where we're kind of saying this thing exists but how can we trust that it's going to
exist how can we trust the designer is actually going to make the thing that we need them to make
or you know ourselves at a later date how are we going to trust ourselves the reason this
works is the blueprint will actually fail to compile if it's not compliant with the underlying
native code so bind widget essentially signals to the blueprint layer hey I need a widget of
this type with this specific name to work properly so you need to add one this kind of manifests
itself in a compilation failure and there's also I don't know what version of Unreal they actually
introduced this but I don't think this used to be the case but when you have widgets that
implement bind functionality such as our segmented bar widget any bind widgets there's actually a
separate window that highlights all of the kind of bindable bits of information and they'll show
you you know there is a there is a this is the kind of this is what the widget type is
this is what the widget is called and there's this kind of like little health check to tell you oh hey
we've got a binding here we'll get into actually this is an example that we'll jump to later but
it's just kind of worth highlighting that as well as just the pure compilation failure
um you can also there's this kind of separate window that is going to highlight to you you
know exactly what bindings it's looking for ahead of time and what those things are meant
to be called and what type they're meant to be so it's just a very very helpful little window
um yeah so but yeah the blueprint is going to fail to compile and we've got that bind
window functionality so we talked about bind widgets uh synchronized properties is something
else we're going to mention um this is a virtual function that we can override to
develop smart responsive ui tools so in many ways it kind of mirrors on construction or post
edit property virtuals that we would see when we're working with actor classes so for anyone
who's familiar with those things um it'll be called every time a property changes
within a specified widget in both the designer and it can get called at runtime not in exactly
the same way it does in designer so don't let that that can be a little bit confusing
it's not every time a single value changes um but it does have um it
when our when our widget at least gets constructed and needs to pass our information down to slate
at runtime that is when um our synchronized properties get called but anytime we're
changing data inside our designer it will get recalled because our entire widget gets
reconstructed the the kind of key point in here is it's not just runtime it is also in
design time so um we're able to respond to changes made in design at design time and
give visual feedback obviously um it's you know probably quite important to know whether or not we
are currently working in a design time environment or runtime logic so there is also an is is design
time function that we can kind of use to branch to you know if we need to do particular design
time behavior or you know ignore certain bits of behavior that we would only be able to
trust because they they're referencing things that we know will only exist at runtime or
something like that we've got this is design time function to kind of let us know about that
it's worth noting that synchronized properties has quite a lot in common with another function
called pre-construct which we'll bring up again later but pre-construct was a later introduction
to umg as part of u4's life cycle and there are some relatively subtle differences between the
two things but the biggest one is that synchronized properties isn't exposed to
blueprints or it's a c++ only function secondly pre-construct is defined in in user
widgets so pre-construct is a user widget downwards function that is exposed to blueprints
whereas synchronized properties is available to is only in c++ but it's available to anything
u widget and downwards and you know part of synchronized properties responsibility is not
just to communicate information from blueprint down to your c++ but it's also to communicate
information from the umg down to the slate so it's already being used for something
something else as well which is also worth mentioning that it's very important that when
you're doing a synchronized property when you're overriding your synchronized
properties functionality that you do call your super function because like i said
synchronized properties is also responsible for communicating information down from your umg down
to slate so if that parent function isn't called suddenly your slate widget isn't going
to work properly and you know your slate widget is what you actually see on screen what you
actually click on so that that's quite important but yeah again the discrepancies between
pre-construct and synchronized properties if you actually dig into the the c++ you'll see that
they're actually called in quite similar ways at quite similar times so you can kind of see
they they do perform a fair amount of similar functionality they both have this kind of
capability of both design and runtime implementation so if we were to kind of look at a practical
example i've kind of already prefaced this a little bit by opening up that widget before
um but this is how we might use a bind widget in in combination with synchronized properties to
kind of make a setup that we were to do the c++ code and kind of know how it's going to work
but we actually don't need to worry about the like real detail about where are these widgets
going to go how are they going to be laid out with each other how are they going to be colored
it's not our responsibility the only bit that we care about is we just need widget x and we're
going to do y thing with it everything else is kind of up to the designer so what we've got
here is a kind of widget that is meant to represent a kind of a health bar and the kind of key
elements here is well i can actually just jump to the c++ function rather than using the slide
presentation here so if i just jump to a 115 section again if you have this project
downloaded all of this this code will be available to you so you can look at this
c++ code in your at your own leisure so we've got this relatively simple segmented bar widget
you can see this is a c++ class that inherits from user widget we've got our synchronized
properties function which we've already mentioned we've got a construct function we don't need to
worry too much about that but we've also got our various variables and importantly here we've
got a t object pointer we talked about this in maybe our first session maybe our second i'm
pretty sure it was our first t object pointer basically being the kind of more modern version
of just a kind of raw pointer so this could just as easily be look like this but t object
pointer has certain editor time kind of advantages over you can spend your own time
looking into that if you're not kind of familiar with that either way we were saying
there's a there's a kind of a widget of type horizontal box and it's called hb segments
we've marked this up as a bind widget so essentially say we're going to act as though this
widget exists but the burden is kind of on the designer or whoever is making the blueprint
that implements this widget to actually make sure that this gets created then we've got
some additional bits of information we've got like a segment class we've got the number of
segments we want we've got some padding between those segments we'll also come to
this in a little bit but we've also got a a bindable widget animation so if we go into
our c++ we can see the kind of most of the heavy lifting here is being done inside our
synchronized properties as i as you can see first and foremost we're calling our super function
because we want our code to work and then you can see we're doing this is design time check
this isn't particularly important i don't actually need to do this here because this this
functionality would be just as valid in runtime it's just i've kind of just put this here to
show you us using it to say you know if we're not in design time then we don't want to do
this but actually in in reality there's there's no reason why we wouldn't want to do that i'm
kind of just showing it off but the kind of other important element here is that hypothetically
there are scenarios where synchronized property could get called whilst our bind widgets are null
so it's quite important to do the this null checking if you're going to be relying whilst we
can like trust that someone else does have to make this until if they try to compile or
utilize this widget until that bind widget is actually properly set up this is going to be null
so one of the other things we should be very careful about is when we're trying to use this
functionality when we're trying to use bind widgets we should be checking for it out these things
are null first to make sure we're not actually just you know getting a null reference exceptions
and things like that and then we just get hard crashes so the logic here is relatively simple
we've got this horizontal box we're calling clear children this is a kind of general function
you can call on most panel type widgets and it just essentially says remove every element that's
currently inside this panel and kind of discard them and then we're just doing a for loop for
our segment count which by default is 10 so from 0 to 10 and for everything we're using this create
widget we've already talked about this and again one of the viable things to pass in as an owner
of a widget is another widget and we are inside a widget so this is fine and then we're just
passing in this segment widget class again we've checked up here whether or not that's null
so we wouldn't even get here if it wasn't if it was sorry no and then last of all
where now that this has been created we're adding that created widget to our horizontal box
and typically this is a kind of this isn't a hard and fast rule if you created your own panels
you wouldn't have to do this but there's this typical kind of thing there's these add child to
panel functions and normally what they'll do is return a reference to the slot that now contains
that child and that lets you do things kind of layout data about that slot and so in this
context we're using that opportunity to get hold of the horizontal box slot that this
new segment is now inside of and we're setting our padding so this segment padding can kind of
come into play i pressed f11 there accidentally and now it's trying to do a build sorry about
that um yeah and you can see we're just uh relying on our padding padding is basically an
amount it's relative the name kind of does what it says in the tin but padding is basically
the amount that a widget kind of sets itself away from other widgets
so the c++ there's relatively simple um just see if there's anything else i kind of want to mention
there well i guess we'll go ahead to the bind widget animations first and then we'll kind of
actually just demonstrate that working um so next up we have bind widget animations we've kind
of already prefaced this a little bit this essentially does exactly the same thing that
you would expect it's a it's a bind widgets but it's specifically for animations um so this
essentially does allows us to specify an animation say you know i'm gonna rely on this animation
existing but it's not my responsibility to make that animation either myself at a later date or
someone whoever is doing the blueprint that implements this c++ class is the person who
has to make the animation and that animation just needs to have a particular name no matter
what kind of animation it is um all animations are u widget animations so whereas with um bind
widgets you kind of have to make sure that the name is right and the type is right with widget
animations they're all widget animations so the only thing you actually need to worry about is
that the animation name is correct um and yeah the other kind of thing is specifically for
bind widget animations they need to be marked as transient you'll get complaints if you don't
do that so just a little thing to kind of bear in mind there and yeah i think that's that's
kind of everything we're talking about here for the the bindables let's just quickly demonstrate
this working so as i said we've got a uh i've made a widget that inherits from our um our
segmented bar widget you know this could be a health bar this could be an xp bar this could
be mana whatever you like um but this is kind of just to demonstrate that functionality you
can see we've got our our bind widgets all kind of set up you can look at my hierarchy it's
relatively simple really um i can add obviously as much as i like i can wrap this um horizontal
box inside a border if i like i can and i'll make that border just like dark red so that it's kind
of clearer um and i could add i don't know uh i could wrap that inside a another horizontal box
and i could say uh put a text block next to it um and just say health if i'm going to spell it
right and then i can make this fill up the rest of the space um so you can see that clearly
the um the there's no complaints here right even though there's a huge difference between
my horizontal box being the only widget in the widget and being inside a border which is inside
a horizontal box but clearly the only thing that the c++ cares about is that there is a widget with
this name that it is a horizontal box um and we already kind of showed some of the variables that
are available but we've got the segment count and you can just see as i'm changing that
this is cool every time i'm changing this our synchronized properties function is getting
called again and so we can kind of respond obviously there's no currently no rule saying that
i i need to um not extend outside the bounds of my widget if i did want to very very quickly
do that i could actually specify some clip bounds so i could just go to my horizontal box
and just do clip oh for some reason the c key button on my keyboard is temporarily not working
if i um specify some clip bounds then we would actually get slightly more sane looking behavior
but what that would that wouldn't actually reduce the um number of uh we still actually
have 87 segments here you just can't see them uh but that is a way that we kind of solve that
problem um so again as you can see uh it doesn't care about the rest of the hierarchy
doesn't care what else is going on in this widget it just cares that there's a widget called
segments and again just to demonstrate what would actually be happening if we didn't have this
set up correctly even something as minor as a change to say hey hb segments two um and then
i go to compile you can see it's no longer filling with data properly and we're going to get
a complaint that you know there's this data that should be bound but it's not bound we can
go to our bind widget and say hey i'm looking for a widget called hb segments um but it's not
found so you know this the spelling is is very very important here um and the same thing applies
to our animations um whereas you know again we uh if i were to make um let's just temporarily
call that hb segments e a segment and if i make a vertical box and call that hb segments
or i don't know why it doesn't oh it's probably not letting me do that essentially it's uh it's
looking specifically for a horizontal box called hb segments um even if there's a another widget
with the same name but it's a different type that's not going to be suitable either is all
i'm trying to say with this um but the kind of that same burden of type isn't there for our
uh for our widget animations because all widget animations are widget animations
so all you need to do there is make sure that you have the animation has the right name
regardless of what the animation is doing you could do a million things you could do one thing
you could do no things there just needs to be an animation with that name in this context
i've just made an appear animation which is going to fade our widget in using our render
opacity from zero to one um i'm not actually using this anywhere i don't think oh or am i
um if i go to our construct oh i am actually playing it when we play construct well done me
um so yeah you can see i'm utilizing in c++ there um but we've got the same problem here
so if i go to our animations thing and i just change this to anim appear i just do a little
typo and i forget the r suddenly i we're gonna get complaints um and you know it's gonna say
you know it's gonna say you know this this doesn't work we're expecting an
animation called anim appear anima pia doesn't count um so names really matter here and again
you can see i've uh it's very easy to forget that you're still in animation mode
so i'm clearly still got that animation selected just need to select off that